you got anything better down there
Johnny a lot of bent rods
so we're just getting set up right now
on the Regal sword we made the move down
from crab legs last night I might just
set up right in here yeah
you know you just get panic in panic
mode about not getting a paycheck and
going home we're 90 miles away
a lot of fuel you know probably four to
six hundred dollars worth of fuel you
just want to make a paycheck you want to
be in the Black by the time the Trip's
over we came down here to pick up right
where we left off last season but so far
that hasn't been the case I'm really
feeling the pressure to get some meat on
deck and defend our title
lock in we're walking
[Music]
yeah buddy
see the right one go
go there you go
[Music]
we need this fish bad we've got to get
one today we already get guys ahead of
us on the leaderboard a nice fake fish
here we'll certainly make up some ground
we got a lot of work to do it and land
this one though
I'm gonna take over for a bit Johnny
yeah you're good yeah you're not
let me
yeah we've been doing a lot of reverse
right now
just trying to keep up with this fish
he's just uh plugging away so hopefully
we can eventually get this fish straight
up and down and fight them all we want
forward
oh you kidding me awesome
that's around his tail oh
jump in for a while Johnny yep
he's kind of all over the place he just
kind of keeps wanting to go to One
Direction so we have to pour it in
reverse the whole time on him he won't
settle into anything here so we want to
get him up and down but we can't
we're on a real one this time you know
no small fish today we need to get this
one there's a few people already on the
leaderboard ahead of us you know this we
only got limited days we can fish this
year we got to make sure every fish
counts and we need to get this fish
badly this fish is acting like a jerk if
I'm being honest kept swimming away and
Away in a way we finally got him up and
down here
it's got to be wrapped so be ready here
oh yeah oh yeah
there you go man he was hooked in the
tail oh wow
holy crap are you kidding me
oh my God he's a monster
[Music]
yeah neither that one boys either that
one if you know it was a heavy fish just
because you can feel the weight on the
line but you could feel the paddle of
his tail the whole time but he wasn't
tail wrapped well you figured it was
foul hook somewhere but Hook is in the
tail look at that wow that right there
is some damn good luck
[Music]
oh we needed that
must be nice
bad tuna just got one uh jealous
so jealous
whenever you're ready oh yeah whoa boys
round let's put a tape on it
95. yeah
heck yeah boys nice heck yeah all day
long
let's get this guy cleaned out iced up
let's head home baby
that's incredible
[Music]
thank you